what Francis is doing is leading the way
for other Fighters that are stuck that
feel like they have no voice that feel
like the UFC is the only show in town
even if they're mistreated what Francis
is doing is he's taking the hits for
them going no no look there is a way to
do this there's another route you can go
shout out to to his agent you know who
took off Markel took all this what are
you doing you ruin his career what's up
now
what's up now you know yeah they made
the right decision they went they
crawled through some like Andy Dufresne
they came out on the other side another
fighting Tyson Fury it takes cojones
dude yeah he went through remember the
taxi guy the racist attacks the he
went through he went through
it must feel good they knew what they
were doing shout out to Markel man you
did it brother proud of you man and
Francis my god dude this is insane this
is history dude